all right so grab a book today national
read across america day
we're celebrating that it's a day
created by the national education
association to
get kids excited about reading and
bianca holman is live now with more on
that hey bianca good morning
okay good morning alex so as our schools
are reopening our libraries are
reopening at 50 percent so this is a day
where you can
curl up grab a book and read with your
child to encourage the love of reading
because we know just how important it is
as they move throughout their school
career and on to being
great adults and of course not just kids
are reading but teens and adults as well
should engage with the book today and
many in-person
in-person guest readers like we've had
in the past those visits have been
canceled because
of the pandemic there are still ways to
encourage a young reader though
nea's read across america theme this
month is compassion
they're encouraging districts to think
outside the box to help kids build a
love for reading
we spoke with one pre-k teacher at
rainbow dreams early learning academy
about their day full of reading
rhyming and fun
a lot of times we know that if they
can't read by grade three
then that's kind of an indication that
you know we gotta do something to help
so starting them while they're young
starting them while they're three while
they're four and getting them excited
about reading is really what we're
trying to do here and i think it's going
to
just be an exciting day
so here are some tips for early readers
first model
reading for your child be an example for
them next while you're reading to your
child have them make predictions using
the pictures
or explain what's going to happen before
it happens and before reading the
passage to them
and finally have the student pick out
words they recognize in the book that
are repeated throughout the book that
can help them build their confidence and
help celebrate small wins
and of course several other pre-k
academies across the valley are have
some activities planned socially
distanced of course
but again to foster that love of reading
for our youngest
readers and early childhood readers
reporting live from torrey pines in west
charleston bianca holman 8 news now
all right thank you so much bianca